[Music]
well from the very beginning we wanted
this to be a very different console from
the evolution of where we've been Scott
a da Meyer yes a senior designer on the
industrial design team so a lot of great
care was taken when we're designing the
industrial design of all of our products
so that it fit together as a family
right there's a cohesive design language
that ties all of our products together
in this generation and we had to come up
with something that would really
encapsulate all those components in a
very efficient footprint but still be
compelling so we wanted this to really
fit in with the things that are you know
in your living room or your game room
you know previously we were a you know a
vertical icon it really stood out with
this we want it to be very quiet very
confident but still very capable so
instead of having a standard Chrome or a
standard black you know we have our very
specific Xbox own dark chrome and even
down to the micro detailing we have a
new key for the ABXY button there's
three injection molding processes that
go into making this key and it becomes a
new almost a Nuke icon when you're
looking at the controller itself the
controllers for me are you know just I
love seeing the things that weren't done
the design pitch that weren't adopted or
did you guys machine these or these 3d
printers so these are 3d printed we have
this on site so this is something that
we can iterate on very quickly what we
did was really tried to streamline a lot
of the things that were I wouldn't call
the problems of the real controllers but
things that we can improve upon all of
this is integrated into one you know
simple shape everything's clustered
together so it's it's easier to reach
it's easier to get a you know rapid fire
from trigger to trigger getting rid of
this battery pack was a huge deal so now
different size shaped hands can get in
there it's much easier to hold it's much
more comfortable after a couple hundred
controller mock-ups and what 100
versions of the Kinect sensor is there
one that we can actually take a look at
yeah got one right over there
here we are I mean these are here are
the babies it's meant to tie in with
things that are already already seen in
your your entertainment systems in your
home so really again it's supposed to
reinforce it this is more of an
entertainment box there's this element
upon element upon element
took great great care with all of our 3d
prints and all of our development we're
really really proud of this product
it's got thanks so much for being here
and for for showing us the final product
my pleasure
[Music]